get started with the afternoon session
uh noah will tell us about uh lp norms
and uh a little dance for us right uh
it's a mysterious wiggle oh
no it's not me
sorry
if necessary
or if there's sufficient demands i
suspect there isn't um okay yes i'm
going to tell you about um lattice
problems in different norms um and i'm
going to tell you about this very
mysterious wiggly thing that
i like to talk about um and okay this is
like um uh uh i'm really like talking
about three different papers um uh the
first one was uh uh this really big
breakthrough um by by eisenbrand and
vincent which actually happened and i'll
sort of tell my own personal story of
learning about this result um during the
simon's uh uh
thing two years ago um although they
weren't here it just happened at the
same time um and then there's sort of
like a paper that uh uh i was a part of
um uh uh that followed up on this and
now sort of uh uh uh the current best
results are good at rothbust events but
anyway i'll tell you this whole story
um so okay it's a talk on lattices i
should tell you what a lattice is uh
probably many of us know but it's a
discrete set of vectors in n-dimensional
space yeah uh here's a lattice in
two-dimensions it's very pretty it's
specified by uh linearly independent
vectors b1 through bn so here's a basis
for this lattice and the lattice itself
is the set of integer linear
combinations the basis vectors of course
these are very nice algebraic objects
but we're interested in in their
geometry so like maybe the most like
fundamental geometric quantity that
we're interested in is what we call
lambda 1 which is the minimal non-zero
length of a non-zero lattice vector yeah
um of course every lattice has zero in
it that's not very interesting what's
interesting is is uh the minimal length
of a non-zero uh lattice vector
um and okay normally like you know
between friends or whatever when i say
uh the norm of the lattice spectre which
happens quite a bit um i mean uh uh
uh i mean yeah
i mean uh uh the l2 norm yeah but like
um uh there are other norms as well
right so there's like the lp norm which
is like the sum of the
absolute values of the coordinates of x
raised to the p power and then okay
raised to the one over p
um all right so the l2 norm is just a
special case of this when you plug in p
equals two and like okay we all really
love the l2 norm yeah like i hope we all
agree it's our favorite norm like you
know it's been good to us um uh but it's
not exactly clear what's so special
about it i mean uh uh it's beautiful but
like maybe we care about other norms too
and these are very nice generalizations
and in particular there's also the l
infinity norm which is the limit as p
goes to infinity it just gives you the
maximum uh absolute value of a
coordinate and you could be even more
general yeah so like uh boaz kind of set
me up for this but um uh there's like a
a very simple relationship between norms
and
um symmetric convex bodies right so
um if i give you a norm then i can
define a an associated symmetric convex
body which is just a unit ball of the
norm right so in other words the l2 norm
like literally it is the ball the l2
ball um for the l infinity norm the the
associated ball is is the cube right
um uh uh but i can go the other way too
right if you give me a convex body i can
define a norm it should be symmetric um
i can define a norm it's just like the
minimum that i have to of the scaling
that i have to scale up the body in
order to uh get x inside of it right
like this is an equivalent way of
defining for example the l2 norm and uh
it generalizes quite nicely
um
okay so uh and you know the the the
study of lattices and convex bodies are
quite deeply inclined um like you know
if you've heard minkowski's complex body
theorem that's a deep relationship
between the two um okay and i'll use the
notation like lambda one to some powery
thing to mean like lambda one in various
norms so this is lambda one the l two
norm the infinity norm and some
arbitrary k norm
yeah okay
um uh so i'm mostly gonna be talking
about the shortest vector problem
uh so uh which i'll write is svp sub k
to specify what norm i'm talking about
um
uh and the goal here is just output a
shortest non-zero lattice vector um uh
uh where shortest here means in terms in
terms of whatever this norm is
uh uh so maybe this is a solution
depending on your norm and
uh uh this lattice um but like we care
about this problem so much and it's so
important to us that like we're okay
with approximation factors right so um
uh we often actually work with gamma svp
sub k which is um uh the approximate
version of this problem where the goal
is to output a nonzero lattice vector uh
uh whose length is within a factor um
gamma of of the minimal i suppose this
norm should say norm sub k i'm probably
gonna drop a bunch of sub k's everywhere
it's quite annoying um okay um uh so
maybe this is a solution uh uh uh to
this problem
um uh and this is known to be hard for
example for gamma less than n to the one
over lag log n there's some question
about which norms this is known for
which it isn't but let's not worry about
it too much um uh and what's really
beautiful okay there are many things
that are really beautiful about this
problem one thing that's really
beautiful about this problem that kind
of came out during huck's talk i think
scott asked a question about it is that
like this problem is interesting for a
really wide range of approximation
factors yeah so like uh uh like
approximation factor two to the n i
guess when i first show you this it's
like not clear at all what a reasonable
approximation vector is you just kind of
have to get used to it i don't know that
there's any real intuition but like
approximation factor two to the n that's
the ll algorithm right so that's like
one of the most important algorithms of
of the 20th century this was both
centuries um uh uh so that's super
important um approximation factor one
that's the exact problem that's very
important um uh in between you get
really interesting things too like you
get crypto around a polynomial um in n
uh for this talk um for the most part
let's think of gamma as like a very
large constant which like i'm just gonna
arbitrary like right like a hundred or a
thousand or whatever when i mean
arbitrarily large constant um okay
cool
um and unfortunately i have to discuss
cvp just a little bit i don't really
want to have to discuss cvp but but i do
um so i'm going to say it really quickly
and i'm going to use this in one place
and then we'll all not worry about it
too much so um in cvp in addition to
being given as input a basis for a
lattice you're also given a target and
the goal is to find a lattice point
that's close to the target um there's an
approximate version of the problem just
like for svp uh where you can find an
approximate closest vector to the target
yeah and again it like is defined in
terms of some norm and you'll see
there's one annoying place where this
comes up where i have to switch from sdp
to cvp and i'm going to be very upset
about it okay
good uh what we know about this is that
uh gamma cdp is at least as hard as uh
svp this is a beautiful result um by
goldrich machandra safro and cipher
and uh it's a really really strong
reduction in the sense that it preserves
the approximation factor it preserves
the norm um uh it's super efficient it
essentially preserves the lattice not
quite but it preserves for example the
dimension of the lattice
um
uh uh
uh and like another like like
heuristic-y thing is that as long as the
approximation factor is not tiny things
get weird as the approximation factor
approaches one for some reason but as
long as the approximation factor is not
too tiny the algorithmic state of the
two problems is pretty similar this is
a a bit of a lie but is what i want you
to think for this talk okay so now let
me tell you a story
um so let me describe the world before
may 7th 2020. so i'm sure we all
remember where we were on may 7th 2020
it was a big day um a pandemic was going
on i was in berkeley but locked in my
apartment um uh and here's what the
world looked like at least like to a
nerd like me like this this is my
picture of the world um
right so this is the complexity or
some some things that we know about the
complexity of um uh sap and the l2 norm
um
uh uh on may 7th 20th and maybe i should
just specify this part hasn't changed
yeah so this is this is still what i
know today um uh uh so what we knew so
like here like this green line is uh uh
like the best proven upper bound this
red line is uh represents lower bounds
that we know under various complexity
theoretical conjectures and this blue
line is what everyone thinks is true um
uh uh more or less everyone who thinks
about these problems uh uh has more or
less the same opinion on on where what
the right answer is
um
and okay i mean you know there there are
decades of work represented by this this
poorly drawn graph um uh you know this
two to the end time algorithm for exact
scp is very exciting um uh it turns out
that for large constant approximation
factors we know how to do slightly
better than for the exact problem um uh
and then for polynomial approximation
factors um we know like a smooth time
approximation factor trade-off um
uh uh but in this like sort of trade-off
regime uh you still get exponential
running time right this is the part
that's relevant for crypto and it's kind
of nice that like the running time is
like literally like two to some constant
times n as opposed to like two to the
square root n or something scary like
that um
uh uh and what we think is actually true
is basically the exact same thing just
the constant the exponent goes down a
little bit
um uh and what we think like notice that
this the scale of this graph first of
all doesn't make any sense but second of
all is ridiculous right in the sense
that like uh these are constants and
then here i'm moving between different
polynomials right so like the scale
changed tremendously here and so like
like somehow the fact that this is flat
here and then eventually starts going
down like actually makes a lot of sense
because like if somehow this function is
sensitive to different polynomials it
shouldn't be sensitive to different
constants uh uh keep this in mind uh
because it's gonna be false um uh okay
uh uh and we know some uh uh uh hardness
like we know that at least for like the
exact or even the near exact problem um
uh we don't expect to get like huge
improvements like we're not gonna find a
2 to the n over 10 million time
algorithm or a 2 to the square root n uh
uh time algorithm for scp um uh
uh uh we know that under fine grain
hardness assumptions um and huck talked
a lot about how like we know barriers to
polynomial time algorithms all the way
up even to slightly super constant
approximation factors
good super constant approximation
vectors
yes
um
it's a very good question um
oh yeah so i think the question is i
understand it is like this is a
presumably an asymptotic picture it is
an asymptotic picture um what about like
concrete like if the dimensions you know
347 or whatever like what do things look
like um i think like
broadly roughly the same um uh uh in
some in some not too small dimensions uh
the fastest known algorithms are not the
same as the
uh uh fastest asymptotic algorithms but
uh they're similar
yeah
yeah so this trade-off kind of keeps
going i i debated just writing the
trade-off maybe i should have but um you
get like a
for n to the c approximation you get a 2
to the n over c time algorithm
did that make sense
um and that that works even when c is
not a constant so maybe i shouldn't have
called it c
okay cool
um
uh uh okay and uh yeah you can you can
look up like like uh uh an actual
uh uh write-off of the current
state-of-the-art uh uh and
uh to find this on my website for
example
um uh but okay like some things to
notice so this blue line the reason we
think we know the right answer is
because we have heuristic algorithms
that achieve this we just don't know how
to prove that they're correct right it's
tyson the audience
um and
uh
uh and like the reason we think that
this blue line
is can't be brought down so we think it
can we think it like it's it's uh uh we
know it's at least this low the right
answer is at least this low because we
have heuristic algorithms that very
clearly work we just don't prove it um
we think it can't be broken brought down
or at least a lot of people think this
can't be brought down because if you get
a much faster algorithm for svp
essentially for any lower approximation
factor than some threshold here um uh
then crypto gets broken in practice
right so like um uh you know in theory
the assumption uh uh uh that that uh
crypto is secure is like no polynomial
time algorithm but in practice the
assumption that crypto is secure is the
algorithms that we know are the best
algorithms up to a very small margin
yeah um okay so like that lower bound
like or that blue line is hopefully uh
in the right place um okay so if you
want to break crypto you you uh go below
this blue line um if you want to break
complexity theory you go below the red
line yeah
okay
again sap infinity the picture maybe it
looks similar but it's actually like
much less interesting um uh uh or at
least it was this is in may 7th 2020
right um uh uh in the sense that like
there hadn't been a ton of study on
algorithms for this problem so devesh
has a very nice paper with uh bianco
muda padilla um uh uh which i think is
like the only paper to like really
directly try to get a constant in the
exponent um uh before that paper we just
only had two to the order writing time
algorithms for this problem where the
the constant in the exponent wasn't even
specified and like this makes sense
right like we all love the l2 norm like
we think about it all the time i do at
least we all do right like we live in it
um but uh uh the only thing or people
have put much less effort into what
people really like the infinity norm for
though is um
uh that in the olympia norm you can
prove lower bounds uh uh uh so the
elephant norm um uh uh really lends
itself to proving lower bounds and huck
kind of showed why in his talk uh it was
it was a very brief moment in his talk
but he like pointed out that like this
gadget that he needed was like trivial
it's just the identity matrix um in in
the elephant norms this goes all the way
back to venom de boas in 78
something like this um
uh uh whereas was a huge open problem to
prove any hardness whatsoever in uh uh
in the l2 norm for for for two decades
um uh in fact we know like very strong
fine-grained hardness results um for
uh uh for stp and the infinity norm um
in particular um
uh uh we know under scth a reasonable
complexity theoretical conjecture we
know that there's no algorithm that runs
in time better than two to the n um uh
and that's even true
um uh for small constant approximation
factors
um uh where there's some trade-offs
that's not actually explicit between
like the con the approximation factor
and the lower bound that we get um uh uh
so in particular like this really really
really suggests
this is where i want to lie to you that
this really really really suggests that
we're not going to see what we see in in
the l2 norm right in the l2 norm we can
do better than two to the n right a
little bit better and we think we can do
way better for constant approximation
factors here we know that for small
constant approximation factors that's
impossible unless complexity theorists
are very sad um uh so probably just for
constant approximation factors is not
going to happen yeah so the difference
between the two pictures of course only
makes
sense in the low gamma regime right
because otherwise yeah so in the high
gamma regime at some point you just hit
the case where if you want an l infinity
short vector you find an l2 short vector
and you say yeah that's pretty sure no
infinity too that's fine right you lose
the square root n factor uh which is
actually what happens right here um uh
yeah so for large approximation factors
they're the same up to this sort of
shift by a square root of
okay
[Music]
yes this is a great question um i
thought a decent amount about it um the
gaussian is really nice
so like uh like a lot of our best proofs
for like anything in lp norms go through
l2 norms because the gaussian's really
nice
um
so
uh i mean there is lwe right in the like
in uniform error which is kind of the
infinity norm
um but i don't think there's like a
there was a paper recently forgetting
the authors um on top of my head showing
that like you can go from sdp and the
affiliate norm to uh lwe uniform error
but you get worse parameters than what
you would get if you went through the l2
norm along the way um so uh uh
yeah i think
either the l2 norm is really nice or we
understand the l2 norm really well um or
relatively well but like somehow like
everything almost everything we do works
way better in the ultimate arm does that
make sense
okay so like the lwe reduction or dead
uses this discrete gaussian right and he
uses a lot of properties industry
gaussian some of them implicitly i mean
the main thing is just that it's fourier
transform it's it's own fourier
transform uh it decays quite rapidly
yeah yeah it's sort of optimal in africa
yeah
let's not dwell on this but just the
small combat the l2 norm has vastly more
symmetry
than any other norm is mentioned here
that that's what makes all the
difference
the l alpha norm has maximal symmetry
among norms
that's more larger symmetry it has much
more symmetry than it has the whole
orthogonal group
it's a pervasive theme in mathematics
yeah
yeah you're setting me up i appreciate
it so like
um uh uh because obviously the picture
is that the l2 norm is the easiest norm
to work with by far right and and and
yeah i guess as as greg saying there are
reasons for this
i'm saying maybe it's a cultural
phenomenon but no there are in fact
reasons for this um but okay so so two
years ago um i gave a talk not not
dissimilar to this one in which um i
listed a bunch of open problems and i
gave an easy one uh sorry i ranked them
according to sort of ski notation even
though i don't ski um and i gave an easy
one which would just give better
algorithms in the lp norm
and and what i meant by that wasn't like
uh uh uh i wasn't asking for anything
fancy i like really i wasn't asking for
anything useful i wanted lower bounds
for my lower bounds yeah like i've
proven lower bounds on on sap and the
infinity norm so i would really like
someone to show that my lower bound is
tight and that means someone has to find
an algorithm
so that's that's all i was hoping for so
i was hoping that someone would say okay
there's a two to the end time algorithm
for stp and some lp norm um uh p naught
and even integer or whatever uh and then
my lower bounds tight and then i can be
very proud and i can stop thinking about
lower bounds yeah um
uh and uh
it worked may 7th 2020 came around and i
got this email from more expensive um uh
the title was faster algorithms for svp
and cvp uh nlp norms uh a question at
simon so i think uh he'd watch the the
videos of the talks which by the way are
like a tremendous resource um uh uh and
um uh so he was emailing me to answer my
question and i was like oh great like i
hope it's two to the n you know like and
like okay maybe if it's like two to the
two n that's still pretty cool like
that's just the fact or two of the
exponent like among friends not a big
deal
you know but
oh
this is what he sent me
so that's
less than one right
the constant in the exponent is less
than one
but it's only for even b
oh it's for all p
so this is a result that is not well
enough known uh oh i should have said
this at the very beginning of my talk
the main reason i'm giving this talk is
because i think people aren't aware of
these results and i just want to
evangelize for them um mostly not my own
results uh uh i suspect there are many
people in the audience who would be
consumers of these results if they if
they knew about their existence so what
what uh uh
merit sent me was an uh a paper saying
he had an algorithm for two to the zero
point eight uh n uh to the 0.8 uh uh end
time uh uh for for cvp in nlp norms
which particularly implies it for svp
and lp nerds um of course there's this
word approximate here um
oh but like you know my first thought
was like oh okay there's a bug or okay
there's a bug in my uh
uh harvest results oh no um uh
uh and this constant like uh uh if you
if you hang out enough in this in this
uh area you know this constant by heart
this is the best known running time uh
for scp and the l2 norm for a large
constant approximation factor so uh the
specific constant's not so important
it's less than one but like
uh it has meaning just in the sense that
um uh it comes from l2 so basically what
they were saying is lp is just as easy
as also
yeah
and okay the reason this doesn't
contradict my lower bound is because
it's for large constant approximation
factors like you know unspecifiedly
large constant approximation factors
maybe a thousand
um
uh whereas my lower bounds only apply to
very small constant approximation
right now it does later in the talk it
won't i'm going to improve the result so
yeah yeah actually a lot of the stuff
that i'm saying is kind of misleading
until the most recent result
um okay um uh so here's the world after
may 7th
um uh uh this is just svp infinity now
and what happens is for small constant
approximation factors we still know
relatively little like even for very
small we don't even know an explicit
constant in the exponent nobody's sort
of bothered to work it out essentially
um uh but once you get a large enough
constant suddenly this just becomes spp
and the l2 norm uh uh and it just
behaves exactly like that's between the
l2 norm and in particular it goes down
to this specific two to the 0.8 uh
n
um uh and actually
um uh uh as i'll show you later um that
continues for all approximation factors
um so we now essentially know that once
you hit a large enough constant
scp and l-infinity norm um uh uh becomes
more or less the same as scp and the
l-tunnel uh in the sense that our
fastest algorithms for both run at
the same time
um that is that a formal statement that
there is a
one-time preserving and nearly
approximation factor preserving
production
from uh
i mean
okay um uh uh but even before of a
node's question
right
okay so
that means that the blue line here has
to match the blue line so remember the
blue line is our best guess is what's
true it has to match
our best guess as to what's true for l2
right like it's as low as our best guess
for l2 at least for large enough
constants because uh uh uh uh you can
plug in your favorite l2 algorithm um
and uh uh uh you'll get that immediately
um uh uh and it can't be lower because
again if it's lower than that you break
krypton um uh uh so like we
absolutely
really really hope that this is the
right answer um uh what
then what happens here
this is
the thing that confuses me and i'm now
in danger of pointing at a slide and
saying i'm confused about where this
line goes for for ten minutes but i
think i might do that um we'll see how
it goes um uh uh but uh like so what
what the hell happens here right there
um uh and remember like if you go if
this ends up going below the red line
you break fcth that's very sad for
complexity theories and like not only do
you break sth you break it by an
algorithm for scp and the old thing
which like doesn't seem
possible um uh you go here you well you
make even more people sad you break a
bunch of crypto um so again the best
that's known below this like
threshold gamma
is n to the n is that right no there's
two to the order n with unspecified
constant depends on which
dependent b
this is i'm only talking about infinity
because it's a cleaner picture there um
so so
here are the only possible resolutions i
think i'm pretty sure i just used the
law of excluded middle
um
uh so option one is that the line
wiggles
and
i don't know if that just seems totally
reasonable and plausible to you to me it
seems absolutely observed and like i
want to remind you of the ridiculous
scale that this is on
right
right so
uh uh these are constant approximation
factors these are different polynomials
like n and squared and cubed uh uh and
what this is saying is that for constant
you get um uh two to the constant times
n where there's a trade-off in the
constant uh in the exponent as the
approximation factor changes then the
thing levels off at some constant for
some reason and then later for
polynomials it starts going uh it starts
getting the same trade off again
like what's an example of a thing that
does that right like
okay if you don't think that's absurd
then i'm talking nonsense and maybe it's
not observed but to me that's completely
observed
there's something like that for function
field number field
it's
weirdly wiggly but i mean
nobody i think would say oh that's
clearly the best algorithm yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i mean this this has been
like we've always had something that
looks like this for our best known
algorithms we've never thought it was
the right answer
um this is saying that either this is
the right answer it really is a wiggle
or scth is false or lattice based crypto
is way less secure than we think it is
i think those are the only three options
um
uh uh and so probably the most likely is
the weird wiggly line
can you can you explain again what what
the
weird wiggly line is yeah so it means
that like
there's some
like like um uh as i go from i don't
know 10 approximate sp infinity to a
million approximate sp infinity yeah the
the running time goes from i don't know
2 to the 2n to
two to the n
yeah um uh uh and then it levels off
that
it has to level off at exactly
three halves of the n over two but like
it levels off at some explicit constant
and then for very large constants it's
just flat and then it starts seeing you
start seeing the same kind of trade-off
again for polynomials then you start
seeing at order n it's like 2 to the n
over 10 in order uh n squared it's 2 to
the n over 20.
yeah
yeah
so i don't know this is what i call the
the strangely wiggly line i think i'll
write a paper on it it'll be more
explicit um
uh at some point um what's going on on
the algorithmic side like you said this
is the ground truth for best known
algorithm so are you just using like a
completely different algorithm later
like
what do you mean
like
like on the algorithmic side what is it
that makes the problem like starts
becoming easier again later while
there's no improvements like at the
large concept yeah so basis reduction
right so like we know a trade-off
for polynomial approximation factors um
and if for for large constants like
we kept getting improvement it didn't
level off somewhere then that would
break crypto
um
and so and just to clarify you're saying
that smoothing one of the wiggles would
break seth and smoothing the other
wiggle would break krypto yeah i'm not
sure if it's two wiggles or one but yeah
yeah yeah all right we're smoothing it
out in one point yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay
uh
and yeah i mean is it possible that
we're just you know looking at it with a
funny parametrization of gamma and if we
just changed how we were plotting the
range of gammas that it wouldn't
look as wiggly
um
uh i think it's the right way to forever
you mean in terms of parameterizing in
terms of the rank or the dimension or
whatever
well i don't know i mean it's like
you're you're going from
what are you or are all the comments
that are being talked about numbers or
some of them like functions some of them
are functioning some of them are
functions of n so yeah it's very hard to
provide like numbers and functions yeah
no but i think that makes it more
surprising about less surprising
actually right like like because like
somehow for constant approximation
factors the kind of trade-off that you
get is it's still exponential just the
constant changes and then it happens
again for polynomial approximation
factors right these scales are
tremendously different yeah yeah but you
know this is just a feeling i have maybe
maybe i'm crazy okay um
okay so let me actually tell you um uh
how this algorithm works it's like
so i'm going to show you an algorithm
that solves constant factor approximate
l infinity uh spp and the infinity norm
um in a running time that's the same as
what you get for the l2 node
um uh uh and it's it's it's i mean it is
an algorithm but like it's not really an
algorithm it's it's three observations
um so observation numero uno is that the
fastest algorithm for scp in the l2 norm
uh with large constants is 2 to the 0.8
n i think i've said this sentence a
million times in my life um
uh
observation number two is that this
algorithm doesn't just find um an
approximate shortest vector it finds a
gazillion of them in fact defines
exponentially many um
uh and this like you know if you've done
anything with lattice algorithms before
you know that this is a very common
feature yeah i mean this is a sieving
algorithm uh and the two kinds of
algorithms we have are basically sieving
algorithms and enumeration algorithms
and they both very much have this
feature
um uh uh i'm being slightly hand wavy
here because i want to pretend that what
this means is you get exponentially many
is that you can use this algorithm to
get exponentially many distinct lattice
vectors at any radius above say a
constant times l2 lambda 1. um uh that's
not necessarily true because there might
not even exist such vectors um but that
turns out to be the easy case in all
these algorithms so i'm gonna sweep that
under the rug for the most part i'm
gonna pretend i get a bunch of distinct
vectors okay um
observation number three which is like
the only thing that's new um is that if
you have many l2 short vectors
you can use that to get an order one
approximate l infinity shortest vector
and let me tell you how that happens
um so let me scale things so that lambda
one and the infinity norm is one which
means lambda two led to one in the l2
norm is is most square root of right
like cubes and bulbs yeah okay um
uh uh okay so
um
uh uh here's the claim the the geometric
claim it's if you've got a bunch of uh
vectors in n-dimensional space whose um
l2 norm is it most square or down
and they're at least two to the n over
ten of them say these constants might be
wrong they're probably okay though um
then there has to exist a pair of them
that are close
in the infinity form
i'm going to sort of
show you the idea behind the proof of
this i'm not going to prove it to you um
but let's just immediately notice that
this implies this up to this little
annoyance about vectors being distinct
right like in particular if i can get
many l2 short vectors then i can just
check all pairs um uh uh and uh uh i'll
put the the pair whose uh l infinity
difference is minimized and uh uh just
like like even in the worst case like no
matter what there has to be a pair whose
elephant distance is almost a thousand
there's some issue that you might get
zero there's always an issue you come up
with you know your like a crazy fancy
sup algorithm and then oops it outputs
zero this could be a problem it's not an
actual issue here but i'm gonna i'm
gonna ignore it
well um
uh
i don't think the volume argument will
be tight enough you get like a one plus
epsilon to be
i don't think you can quite prove it
directly at the volunteer but uh i'm not
totally sure um uh but what i do is what
what they do is is similar so the whole
point is just you can cover if you take
the root end ball
so in other words the ball l2 ball
scaled up by factor route which is big
enough that it contains the cube the
point is you can cover this um
uh uh by uh two to the n over ten cubes
uh uh with with side length a thousand
um or if you like sort of l infinity
radius 500
yeah um and okay like i'm not going to
show you a proof of this actually by far
the best proof of course uses the
discrete gaussian over lattices um uh
this is really a question about counting
um the number of uh short vectors in in
zm
um uh uh uh think about it sure um
okay um uh uh and just a little
technical detail for those who are like
super into this stuff um uh the specific
properties of the l infinity ball that
i'm using
um uh here is that root n times
uh uh b2 contains b infinity but it can
be covered by many uh
copies so like somehow being covered by
many copies isn't super surprising this
is like an ellipsoidy thing and i'm
going to say more about that later the
fact that it liter that it's literally
contained is is is uh uh uh the magic
here and this is why this doesn't
immediately translate to all norms um
and okay eisen brandon vincent um showed
a similar algorithm that doesn't just
solve scp itself cdp and it works in any
lp node um uh actually like they have
one algorithm for d greater than two and
one algorithm would be less than two
which is a common thing that happens um
so this is crazy but like let's complain
yeah um uh so there are things to
complain about the biggest thing to
complain about here is that it's an
algorithm not a reduction right and why
is an algorithm not a reduction it's an
algorithm and not a reduction because
like i have this list of three
observations right
so like i need an algorithm with certain
specific properties i suppose it's this
one um uh and like you know when you
start dealing with the actual issues
here what you actually need is a rather
subtle specific property i need an
algorithm with specific properties in
order to um
uh to make this work right and that's
like a downer because it means like um
uh you know if someone finds a faster uh
algorithm in the l2 norm tomorrow um uh
uh then um
uh it's not clear what that will say um
about the infinity norm it also only
works at constant approximation factors
um we'd like to say i mean now that we
have this result like now we'd like to
just go crazy and say like okay for all
approximation factors the two the two
problems are more or less equivalent um
but this only works for constant
approximation factors because it's at
constant approximation factors where our
algorithms have this property um
uh
and it only works for um lp
uh lp balls um uh and actually the fact
that it only works for lp balls is more
annoying than you might think because
i've been hiding this entire time the
distinction between the rank of the
lattice and the dimension of elapse
and uh you can do this in the l2 norm
because in the l2 norm um uh if you have
some lattice that's like low rank but
embedded in some gigantic dimension you
can just pretend that you're working
inside the um the span of the lattice uh
because the intersection of the ball
with that subspace is going to be uh a
ball yeah but for lp norms that
completely collapses in fact
intersections with uh uh the cube are
essentially arbitrary convex bodies more
or less
um okay so like what's the smallest
value of 500
small value
did they work it out like uh uh they
didn't we did but i don't know the
answer off the top of my head
um
uh
yeah okay on the next slide i have i
have slightly more detail but not enough
detail for you to actually reconstruct
that um okay uh so now let me briefly
tell you about uh work that i was
actually a part of this is trying to
work with uh divesh who's over there
rajendra who's somewhere um there uh-huh
uh yan linchen zangli and some clown um
uh and you'll notice we got dimension
preserving reductions between spp and
cpp and our main observation which i'm
just not going to tell you about at all
is that um any approximate svp algorithm
or cbp algorithm can be converted into
an algorithm that samples randomly from
more or less the set of solutions to the
problem that itself
um
uh uh there are a lot of details like
what we actually get is subtle
particularly because there might not be
that many solutions in the first place
um
uh but this works and then the key word
is sparsification um uh if you know what
that means so so like you you run this
svp algorithm once per point that you're
getting or somehow you know many times
yeah yeah many times many times yeah
yeah yeah
um
uh yeah so so uh uh right so like yeah
sparsify call it
maybe fail sparsify call it maybe fail
over and over and over again but two to
the epsilon n times
yeah so what we get is two to the
epsilon n time reductions that preserve
the rank in the dimension
uh uh between uh lp and lq norms um uh
we even drew a pretty picture which has
some details in it in case you're
curious um but of course you can you can
look at the paper which even has
explicit constants for what it's worth
um
uh uh
uh so this is cool because like now we
have a reduction um but still
unsatisfying
um uh uh there's like some annoyance
that like for svp q has to be larger
than p for cbp p has to be smaller than
q it's it's very upsetting um uh uh and
this is because of this thing about the
cube i mentioned earlier or whatever um
uh uh but we did in fact show that these
things can be made into reductions and
again like the whole point is that you
can take any algorithm and make it an
algorithm with the property that
eisenberg events needed and this now
works for arbitrary approximation
factors right so you put in any
approximation factor here you get
constant times that approximation factor
there you're running two to the epsilon
end time
um uh but uh uh if you're in the regime
where there's an exponential time
algorithm who cares about a little two
to the epsilon yeah
good great
so
i wonder you know you
you sort of generalize this enough
you
so the lp ball and the lq ball
with the inequality that you got they
they have a certain relationship
like for instance that uh
so
could you define
a favorable pair of convex bodies
that are that don't this aren't
necessarily as special as the lp norms
so i'm about to get for any norm
right so the downside of this is that
again
uh it only works for lp norms and
that's a downside just if you like other
norms but it's also a downside if you
like lower ranked lattices um uh uh
because once you start taking
intersections of subspaces with with lp
norms you just get arbitrary norms
anyway so you might as well talk about
arbitrary um
uh so this was the the the second
surprise from where it's vincent and
uh thomas russell bro
um
um uh uh who showed well they called it
an approximate cvp algorithm for uh in
time 2 to the 0.8 this is the constant
that we're all memorizing now in any
norm yeah so they they they got rid of
the
um uh
this annoyance um
uh uh okay so let me uh tell you they
actually have two theorems so what
what the previous result prevented you
from going to arbitrary norms
discovering this sort of
the covering
yeah yeah yeah so we want yeah okay i
always get confused about this when i
think about it but like you want the
ball to contain the cube like literally
just rigidly contain the cube there
can't be a little uh corner sticking out
and you still want to be able to cover
the
uh
uh ball with this doesn't
i
understand correctly this doesn't quite
obviate what you're doing before because
you get two to the epsilon
so we got reductions that run into the
epsilon end time uh uh one implication
of the reductions that run into the
epsilon end time is that like the uh uh
uh up to the little epsilon which gets
uh swallowed up by this exponentially
you get an algorithm like this what they
actually get is a two to the epsilon
enzyme reduction as i'll show you right
here
um
yeah uh uh so what they actually get is
a two to the epsilon entire uh dimension
preserving reduction from uh uh
approximate scp in uh k norm to cvp in
in the l2 norm right where the constant
uh or the approximation factor just goes
up by some constant which depends on
epsilon um in a not too hideous spread
now
but now it became cv
yeah so this is
this is like as i'll say when i mention
open questions this is the one remaining
annoyance right we need a cvp oracle and
right now that's okay because right now
our best address scp algorithms like
kind of also solve cbp um uh uh but it's
entirely plausible that tomorrow that
won't be true uh in fact that would be a
very nice tomorrow um uh
so this is very sad um they also just to
give a complete list of their results um
for constant factor approximate cvp they
just give an algorithm that runs to the
0.802n
time
for any k but this uh uh it's not a
reduction uh and also i'm trying to
ignore the distinction between cvp and
spp as much as i can so i'm not gonna
say much about this
okay so but this is
if that word s this would be the holy
grail of like this line of research
right
um okay
cool so let me
like briefly run through a high-level
sketch of
slides look much better on the screen
maybe you guys already realize that um
okay um uh so step one or really step
zero in their algorithm is to apply a
linear transformation to k
so that looks roughly like an l2 ball
and okay for annoying technical reasons
it's going to be convenient for me to
meet have it be an l2 ball divided by
20. so the l2 ball of radius one over
20. um now if you do any convex geometry
you know that this is always step zero
right like um in fact there's like a
gigantic body of literature
um uh uh uh asking the question when can
i transform um
a convex body under linear
transformation um uh such that it looks
like an l2 ball
in some specific by some specific
definition of looks like an l2 ball so
here i'm going to show you the algorithm
first and then we're going to back out
what properties of the l2 ball we need
our body to have okay
um so now like our body you know started
out this hideous octagon thingy and now
it's a
less hideous octagon
i think it's enough yet
um
cool um
uh uh so
so like now here's the setup like let's
assume things are scaled so that um the
shortest vector in the k norm has norm
one which means it lies right on the
edge of this body yeah
um so step one of the algorithm is to
sample a target t from a rather funny
set actually uh the set k
plus the l2 ball
um uh so this is like a minkowski song
so this was my artist's impression of
what the uh uh k plus a built-in ball
honestly i feel like i did a pretty good
job um but that's the minkowski song
right so like every in other words it
has uh it goes to
distance exactly one from every point on
the on the edge of this thing
um uh uh so we're gonna sample a
uniformly random point there and we're
gonna hope that we get really really
lucky
right um we're gonna hope that it just
happens that the distance between the
target that i sampled randomly and um uh
the shortest vector v is less than one
this is l2 distance
and like the whole reason i'm doing this
like in in the l infinity case that i
showed you earlier what i needed was a
ball that contained the shortest vector
the shortest l infinity vector yeah uh
uh that's why i needed the ball to
contain the cube here i found a ball
that contains the shortest uh uh uh k
vector turns vector in the k norm um uh
uh the only issue is that's no longer a
centered ball yeah
and fundamentally cannot be a centered
ball if i want the scalings to be
reasonable
okay so that's step one
so now i have this ball that contains
the shortest vector now i'm just going
to kind of do the same thing again so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to um
use a cbp oracle in the l2 norm to find
many random samples from lattice points
that live in a larger ball right so
this ball contains
a lattice vector which means if i call
an approximate cvp oracle
on this target i'll get a bunch of
lattice vectors in in this larger ball
where like the ratio of these two radii
is my approximation factor gamma
yeah
i lost people
um
good so i'm going to get many random
samples so y1 y74 yn
um
uh uh and then finally
uh i'm just going to take this bunch of
uh samples and i'm going to uh take all
pairwise differences measure their k
norm and see which one's smallest um uh
uh i mentioned
briefly there's a corner case when uh
you get the same vector over and over
and over again if you get the same
vector over and over and over again it's
v i'll put that
uh uh but okay that's that's not the
interesting case
um
cool
uh and the reason that this works is
exactly the same argument i went uh i
went through before what you want is you
just want to cover
this ball um uh uh by scalings of k
yeah and if you can cover this ball by
say 2 to the epsilon n scalings
of k
then uh you'll get two points that have
to be in the same scale
yeah just by the picture whole principle
okay
so this is our algorithm um i think the
question is like what do we need uh what
properties do i need of my ball
of k for to work yeah
and uh uh so for step one remember i
sampled um a vector t uh from this like
sum set thing images and i hoped that it
happened to land close to my shortest
vector yeah so what do i need for that i
need the ratio of the volume of this sum
uh
to the volume of the ball itself to not
be too large right i want to land inside
this ball i'm sampling uniformly from
this whole thing so i want the ratio to
not be too large so i want it to be like
two to the epsilon n so to the n over
time
yeah
thing two or thing three really um uh is
that i need as i said uh the ball to be
covered by two to the n over ten copies
of uh the k ball scaled up appropriately
scaled up by some large constant
yeah because then i only need two to the
n over ten samples for this pigeonhole
argument to kick in and for me to get a
difference that's more
okay so those are the two properties
that i need i'm not going to
uh say much more about it except i'm
just going to point out that if k were
actually
a
vl2 ball
with radius 1 over 20 um this would in
fact work yeah in fact it would like
this would be overkill i could cover it
by one copy or whatever
um uh so these two properties together
really do sort of suggest that you look
something like an l2 ball
um uh which is which is what we want and
of course rothwest and benson show how
to not only that such a linear
transformation always exists for any
convex body but that you can find it um
efficiently or i think actually in
quasi-polynomial time but okay um
right yeah yeah so so john's theorem is
one of a long sequence of uh uh theorems
that say in various different ways that
convex bodies look like balls this is
this is way stronger
it's like some sort of
baby lesson yeah this is a much stronger
yes good position here yes
in what sense that you're getting balls
rather than ellipsoids is that no no no
no no no the ellipsoid is just the
winner transformation
um
john's theorem says that
the best ellipsos for a context body is
the largest one
simple argument
the
yeah yeah i mean what this is very
similar to but annoyingly not exactly is
is the amoled
um or i called it m position because i'm
thinking of transforming the body
instead of transforming the ball m
stands for millman all these things have
bad names because they just use initials
anyway
uh yeah this is very similar to em
position actually it's really similar to
uh
uh what was used in the douchebag
where they used some variant of them
ellipsoids as well um uh okay
good right so it's not obvious if these
things exist it's also not obvious you
can find them efficiently but both
things are true
okay um so
uh
might actually finish slightly earlier
which is kind of fun um
uh uh then maybe i will do a dance
um
okay
no i see um okay so in summary um uh uh
we now know that the fastest algorithm
for cvp and svp uh uh in any norm for
constant large constant approximation
factors is this two to the zero point
eight and time algorithm and like you
know go back and check your papers like
i probably saved you a square root and
an approximation factor somewhere like
this should be better known um uh uh
uh
um
um more generally or
yeah more generally um we can reduce uh
std in any k norm uh to cvp in the two
norm um uh just costing us a constant um
uh uh in the approximation factor uh the
penalty that we pay is um uh you have to
run in two to the epsilon end time
um uh and i'm going to go out on a limb
and make a completely ridiculous
statement which is that basically
lattice and problems in any norm are
blend up to a constant approximation
factor um i think that's what you should
get out of uh uh this talk admittedly
it's a it's a warm fuzzy feeling it's
not a a concrete statement um but i just
want to point out this is exactly the
opposite of of of uh what i thought you
know two and a half years ago which is
maybe a good reason not to listen to me
now but
uh uh but this really really changed my
perspective on
svp in different norms which is a thing
i think about quite a lot um
okay
uh uh let me
finish just with some fun open questions
so like kind of the obvious open
question is to
um uh uh to get a reduction from any
norm that goes from scp to spp
yeah
by the way there's nothing super special
about the l2 norm here like probably all
these techniques go from any norm to any
other norm but like
l2 is nice so we've been dealing with
lte we're making the same mistake we
always make focusing too much on the two
um all right so currently we have a
reduction that goes to either gamma cbp
in the l2 norm or you can reduce from
gamma scp in nlp norm for p greater than
or equal to two which is like this one
um
uh uh so that's problem number one
problem number two is figure out the
best running time for scp and the
infinity norm for small constant
approximation factors and in particular
what's the shape of this wiggle yeah it
seems to wiggle how does it wiggle um
and you know if it doesn't wiggle then
break
scth um
uh uh okay
um uh more generally uh what's going on
with with uh stp in uh
uh uh uh arbitrary norms like i feel
like now
that we really have a very nice
understanding of um
large constant approximation factors
let's just finish you know let's just
figure everything out let's just see
what's going on for small constants as
well
um
um uh and then uh uh
this is an extremely ambitious open
problem black diamond maybe it should be
double black diamond uh so the norm
doesn't matter yeah our best algorithms
are in the l2 norm
but who says yeah
so if the norm doesn't matter pick your
favorite norm
solve svp in that norm and back out the
of the l2 norm right i don't think this
has been tried before i don't think
people have been thinking like what's
the silliest norm i can come up with uh
to solve spp in um in particular can you
make a norm since we only have one idea
and it's called sipping get two ideas
saving an enumeration um
uh uh like why don't we just pick a norm
in which sieving works really
beautifully um and actually this is
quite a concrete question in the sense
that there are kind of two things that
control the running time of a sieving
algorithm one is this like sort of
purely geometric thing which is more or
less the kissing number um and the other
is how well we can uh
uh do locality sensitive hashing um uh
so i think you could actually convert
this into a purely uh geometric question
if you stare at it for long enough and
then there's a question can you do
better than l2
um uh uh and uh uh this you know i think
this is a
of the many implausible directions that
we have for
uh breaking lattice crypto this is maybe
one of the most possible
um
okay
thanks
question just to make sure i understand
what you're saying in high level writing
there seems to be two parts to it right
one is you can take any spp to our
and make it produce any random solution
is just one
right and that gives us some properties
of svp's
how shorter sectors why it's on yes
yeah
so uh in some sense that uses too long
who should be at the moment no no no we
can specify any norm no you can do it
for me yeah okay and the second part is
the opinion already
it said once i produced exponentially
too short vectors some difference is
good in the other moments yeah
and that's
that's general right
yeah i mean but
it's
it's uh what's the word i want it's like
it's delicate to make it work exactly
right so like this is why we currently
need cvp yeah it it like morally just
like an emma lip sweaty thing um uh but
getting precisely what you need um uh uh
yeah we're
exactly exactly yeah i care about the
constant right which is which is rare
yeah
well one thing to correct it's not my
idea
okay cool it's eisenberg
yeah yeah yeah yeah cool
so does this imply anything about
hardness uh for for svp in the true norm
right going the other direction right
sure
yeah it would if we didn't already know
it
um like i mean like we have like you
know two to the epsilon or even explicit
constants like two to the n over 100
uh hardness for
stp and some lp norm or whatever i'm
talking about exact hotness for sort of
the
oh sorry
oh i don't mean eph hardness i really
mean like
oh but it runs into the epsilon enzyme
so it needs to be in like the ethg
regime right like yeah yeah although i
should say like
i've been focusing and actually uh uh
rothfuss events and entirely focus on
the regime when epsilon is constant it
doesn't have to be
um you do get some smooth trade-off um
uh but i still don't think
it's gonna buy you
something as strong as hardness uh-huh
you're saying
that would require you to show hardness
and k norms uh to within very large
factors and then vendors exactly exactly
yeah yeah yeah yeah i don't think
there's a regime where it works so
admittedly i haven't sat down written it
down maybe maybe it just does that would
be pretty cool
oh all right let's uh thank god again